you have time at 34 years old when i
started vaynermedia and now it's vaynerx
and at the revenue we're at it's a
billion dollar company if i was to sell
it today it's a big ass [ __ ] company
that's what i actually do when i was
like what does gary vee actually do is
he with the foxy i'm like do you not
know that i run a 1500 person global
like i have a real company
garyvee is my side hustle gary
vaynerchuk runs an actual business but
when i started vayner when i was 34
years old because i was building my
dad's business and because in family
business you don't get paid i had no
[ __ ] money i started vaynermedia in
buddy media's conference room because i
didn't want to have any rent fee
at 34. if you're sitting and watching
right now and you're 28 and you don't
have [ __ ] you can get [ __ ] just cause
you're 31 but your buddy's making a
million on nfts or your best friend's
girls making 4 million tick tock you
don't have to feel like a piece of [ __ ]
we're in the first quarter just cause
you're not winning at 23 or 27 or 32
you're not finished and by the way
what's winning well when is it time to
panic 70.